a la hambruna el enemigo silencioso que
avanza en el conflicto del tigre según
el programa mundial de alimentos casi 7
millones de personas afrontan una crisis
de hambre mientras que la onu advirtió
de la necesidad de acercar ayuda al
norte de etiopía tanto con alimentos
como con otros insumos
[Música]
tenemos un número muy alto de personas
que necesitan ayuda urgente en tigre de
hecho 52 millones de personas requieren
asistencia urgente virginia of systems
el conflicto que estalló hace casi un
año entre el gobierno etíope y el frente
popular de liberación de tigre ahora se
está expandiendo a las vecinas regiones
de amhara y a farc a medida que los
rebeldes tigrillos intentan avanzar en
esas áreas frente al retiro del ejército
etíope en lanzar a las fuerzas tigrillas
han sido acusadas del asesinato de
cientos de civiles algunos de los cuales
se han sumado a las milicias locales en
los combates en el pequeño poblado de
chen a los residentes tuvieron que
abandonar sus hogares
entraron tan pronto como se fue el
ejército en cuanto ingresaron comenzaron
a masacrar a nuestros familiares
tenemos que huir ya no tenemos una casa
aquí nuestra vivienda fue atacada con
artillería pesada demencial humberto las
autoridades etíopes estiman que unas 450
mil personas han sido desplazadas por
los combates en ankara y a farc y más de
2 millones debieron huir de sus hogares
desde el inicio del conflicto en tigres